(upbeat music)
- Elect Donald Trump as our president.
- I'm voting for Hillary
because I'm a feminist
and he's a psychopath.
- I believe that Donald
Trump will lower our taxes,
repeal Obamacare, and just
make America great again.
- I'm voting for Hillary
because in my opinion
she's the most qualified
candidate for the job.
- Hillary and Donald are both very biased,
Gary Johnson is the more honest candidate.
- I'm super pumped to vote for Hillary.
For a woman of color, she
definitely is talking about things
that are important to me.
- Trump is not a career politician.
I believe he's ingenious when
he wants to put America first
and I believe that Hillary
speaks for herself.
- When she first started running
she wasn't my first choice,
but then we had this guy come along
and like it's just so unacceptable
it's not even a choice.
- Hillary Clinton is a war monger,
she's got blood on her hands,
and that's why I'm voting for Trump.
- I believe in net good,
the most good for the
most amount of people,
and I think Hillary is
clearly the candidate
who will accomplish that.
- Honestly, I don't like Donald Trump,
I love him, and I think he's a great man,
and I think he's gonna do great things
when he becomes president.
- I support Hillary because first of all,
that other one don't know
what he's talking about.
I'm afraid of what he'll do.
- He will enforce federal laws,
and he will get rid of Obamacare,
and he will build a wall
to secure our borders.
- I feel really uncomfortable
saying I'm with her
because so much of why
I stand with Hillary
is because I'm in such
opposition to Trump,
which I think is a
frail and faulty system.
With a two-party system,
you're more like to get whoever
is the wealthiest or more
endorsed by wealthy people
as opposed to who might be the
most educated or excellent.
- I'm voting for Hillary
because she's the candidate
with the biggest balls.